let's start up again last round uh from
uh for another hour
thanks for doing that
okay
so
picking up where we left off so
so we spent the last hour
introducing
this representation of mags and tags
talking about fci as a constraint based
approach very similar to pc and it's
like underlying logic
for learning in the space of mags and
pegs
and showed how it could work and some
really simple examples of just a few
variables
um
uh one thing
i
wanted to
so so
there is as i sort of mentioned earlier
there's all this theoretical machinery
for what you can do with an admg
if you have one
within the general class of admgs like
the identification algorithm id
algorithm or
identification results for various kinds
of causal effects and so forth so i want
to spend just a little bit of time uh
mentioning some stuff you can do
with a mag or pag if you have one
because it's not quite the same thing
um so obviously
the mag or peg will represent to you in
a qualitative way ancestral
relationships and some stuff about
confounding right so there's a kind of
qualitative conclusion uh that you can
read off the graph
um
um
one important kind of property as i that
i alluded to earlier is this fact that
some directed edges
uh can kind of hide or be ambiguous
between the existence of only an
ancestral relationship or
both an ancestral relationship with uh
unmeasured confounding and there's a
criterion uh that you can use
uh
thinking about visible and invisible
edges which distinguish between the two
options
so in particular
if i have a mag or a peg it's the same
for both
call it p
and i have a directed edge in that graph
from x to y
we call it visible if there exists a
vertex z
not adjacent to y such that there is an
edge between z and x that is into x
meaning has an arrowhead in x or there
is a collider path between z and x that
is into x and every non-endpoint vertex
on the path is apparent of y
otherwise that edge is called
invisible so what does that mean it's
kind of hard to parse but what does that
mean it says that i'm interested in this
edge between
x and y
and so the first part of that definition
says if there is an edge between
uh z and x that is into x
so i'm going to let this be kind of any
endpoint i want here
um
that is into x and it's going to be
non-adjacent to y
then uh and so that's the first i
part or it could be a bit more
complicated and you could actually have
a z
um that has a collider path so it's not
necessarily directly connected to x but
connected
by
um
a
bunch of
colliders
uh into x
such that every non-endpoint vertex on
that path
is apparent
of
y for example like this kind of thing
so either of these could hold and if
that's the case then this edge directed
edge between x and y is called visible
so ignoring the second part the first
part is kind of
enacting this y structure thing that we
saw previously it's sort of basically
saying that if there's an edge that
looks like this
uh from z to x
and there is no adjacency here it's
going to lead to a kind of conditional
independence between z and y
given x which means it's sort of
incompatible with
a
uh
a unmeasured confounder between
l and y so visible edges sort of are
ones that tell you for sure there is no
unmeasured confounding between x and y
or the graph is incompatible with
unmeasured confounding between x and y
whereas if they're invisible you don't
know
and so so it and the kind of more
complicated clause a generalization of
this logic it basically says that if
there exists this kind of pathway
then
um
the d separation relations would change
whether there's an l there or not so if
there was this kind of pathway then
there would be a
and a non-adjacency between z
and y then there must be a separation
between them
so that it's incompatible with an
unmeasured confounder so that's a kind
of neat
you know i never really think about it
this way i kind of just think about it
as as this kind of thing
it's kind of a neat thing that you can
algorithmically read off of a graph like
you can just ask your computer program
to implement this definition and you can
sort of like highlight the
directed edges that are visible
and are ones that are sort of you're
sure that there's no confounding there
so that's kind of nice so it's not
so i kind of gave mags a hard time
earlier because they're less informative
than a regular admg but they're not
totally uninformative there are things
you can learn about unmeasured
confounding even if there's no
bi-directed edge appearing there
okay
and so that's why when we saw
um
saw that example with the
the y structure in the little r code
there was a directed edge
uh
z1 and z2
there was a directed edge between
x and y in the case where there was no
actual unmeasured confounding between
x and y right when i generated the data
such that the l had no effect on x
right and then when i as soon as i put
that edge in there i no longer satisfy
well
stuff became undirected and i sort of
induced
edges
between z's and y's
make sense
so
yes
there's an interesting question
maybe you could say something about is
there a ges type algorithm so i guess
it's worth this type of algorithm for
knives
good question so the question is if
there's a score based algorithm for mags
and pads i'm sure i'm going to get to
this a little bit later
the answer is
uh basically no i mean there are hybrid
procedures that use some scorn-based
concepts that try and learn mags and
tags but there's no strictly speaking
ges for mags and tags
part of the reason being that
um the
problem of search so in the case of ges
you're searching through the space of cp
dags by adding and removing undirected
edges and there are some nice
theoretical results that tell you how to
do that correctly and that figure in the
proof of its consistency
if i try to do the same thing for mags
and tags i have many more options right
because i can add or remove directed
edges or by directed edges or if i allow
for circles then all of these
combinations of things and so there
isn't really a fully formed greedy
equivalent search procedure for mags and
pads there are
score based things that
are somewhat useful for mags and tags
i'll get to more recent work at the end
of this slideshow so as a quick example
that i won't mention otherwise is
there's a kind of hybrid
ges and fci algorithm called gfci greedy
fast causal inference which basically
uses greedy equivalent search is like
the first step and then unorients things
and then does fci on top and that can be
uh useful just in the sense that it's
faster because you can use ges and it
can scale it up nicely and it can be
more accurate and stable in small sample
sizes but it's not really a full
greedy uh procedure
yes
it's difficult computationally for score
based approach or is it that there
aren't good scores
um it's neither really it's that there's
not really good theory for how to do the
score based search like so in order to
traverse the space of pegs you need to
prove some stuff about
um
edge additions and deletions to a
starting graph and prove that
the way that you do it won't get you
stuck in a local optimum and so there's
that theoretical result doesn't exist i
skipped over in my previous slides but i
had a slide about mix conjecture which
is a kind of theoretical property
uh for
for dags that was not it's not a
conjecture it's a theorem now um and
just there's no mixed conjecture for
mags and tags uh as of yet
but you can still score a mag
you can score a mag yes you can score
right if you if you wanted to do a brute
force thing you can calculate scores for
mags you can calculate likelihoods for
mags i'll mention that a little bit
later but yes
uh
yeah i just wanted to add a very quick
comment there so yeah so you can compute
bic scores for uh mags both with
discrete data
and for um gaussian data
um and
so yes i think it's important to say
that the thing which is lacking is a
proof of consistency or
of some
score-based search
um but you know in in reality
we don't know that
that that's a theoretical property
doesn't tell us within any given time
when you run ges on real data that
you're getting a maximum so
yeah
right so yeah so so there are
theoretical proofs for ges that tell you
uh
in the limit of infinite sample size you
shouldn't get stuck in local optima and
those things are even lacking for for
mags and pags but if you want something
stronger than that
for finite samples would require more
work
yeah
um so i i will i should say we'll talk a
little bit about kind of more
all the methods i'm been talking about
today are
at least 20 years old and i'll talk a
little bit about some that are a bit
more recent um
so um so just to conclude this little
bit uh the definition of visible edges
can be useful uh for reading off um
information about confounding in the in
the
mag or peg that you might learn there's
also a backdoor criterion for mags and
pegs so in the case of dags we know that
one way to find one way to estimate some
sort of causal effect or post
intervention distribution is to do back
door adjustment so adjust for a certain
set of covariates that satisfies pearl's
backdoor criterion um that kind of
criterion has been extended to mags and
packs i'm not actually going to go
through this i'll just leave the slides
for you to
to look into if you're interested but
there is a backdoor criterion for mags
and pegs in the sense that if you're
given a peg or a mag that you've learned
from fci
you can uh define
a certain set
um
what is it here it's called uh dsep xy
as defined here
and you can check a certain graphical
criterion which involves
removing edges from a certain sub graph
of the of the original graph and
checking whether descendants intersect
with certain other sets i won't go into
it but if you satisfy this criterion
then this set d sep that is calculable
from the graph is what is a sufficient
backdoor adjustment set so it means that
um if this criterion is met i can
estimate the causal effect uh by
adjusting for that backdoor set um in
the mag or peg
and uh but it's but there's a lot of
um
uh and actually i should mention that
there's a do calculus for mags and pags
uh which is in the paper i cited earlier
by gigi zhang
in um in jmlr from 2008
uh but it doesn't have it doesn't have
all the quite all the nice properties
that do calculus has for
um
for uh general admgs at least the
version gj did is not complete but then
there's some more recent work by
barenboim and co-authors that adds to
that as well so this is all way of
saying that there's stuff you can do
with a given mag or peg if you're
interested in stuff like backdoor
adjustment or do calculus
but it's not quite as
uh easy or well developed or complete as
the theory for admgs in general and
here's my list of references for all
these papers that i've mentioned
um this first paper
uh
proves and characterizes markov
equivalents for ancestral graphs um
actually this paper by thomas and peter
from 2002 is the one that introduces
ancestral graphs
um
uh
a little bit of kind of very brief
history and thomas can correct me if i'm
wrong but the fci algorithm was actually
first
presented in some papers in the late 90s
with peter and thomas and chris meek
usually the citation for fci is in there
is in the book
by
peter spurdys at all from 2000
but a kind of
confusing thing is that the original
formulation of fci was formulated
without mags and tags really it's
formulated with a different kind of
graphical
representation called partially oriented
inducing path graphs which i think is
maybe
the funniest acronym in
causal discovery like poip g's or i
don't know how you're supposed to
pronounce that
um so the original if you like go to
this book it'll tell you fci and the
output won't look like the output that
we've just discussed here and it was
reformulated to be
represented in terms of mags and pags
only later than that starting with these
papers by
reference ancestral graph models
markov equivalents and in particular
this paper by gigi zhang on uh the
completeness of fci when you interpret
it in terms of mags and pags
um and so forth and then the bacter
criterion stuff i just mentioned is in
this paper by
matuisse and diego colombo and then
another paper
that sort of generalizes fci
or
makes fci more feasible in high
dimensional settings
with some computational changes so if
you want to dive into the literature on
fci and mags and tags this is pretty
much a good place to to look
okay so i'm going to conclude the sort
of fci mags and tag stuff
here
uh talk a little bit about alternative
approaches to calls of discovery that
are not really necessarily
um
direct descendants of of pc and ges
so
uh
so everything that i've discussed so far
today
has placed
uh at least in principle no real
assumptions on the holographical
uh model
except that it's generated from a dag
right they've been kind of
non-parametric as possible they haven't
said anything about structural equation
models
they've assumed that there's data or
there's a distribution that's generated
from a dag maybe it's a dag with
unmeasured variables and that that
distribution has to satisfy faithfulness
with respect to the graph and then
various machinery works through but an
alternative approach has been to place
some assumptions on for example the
structural equation models that you're
willing to assume
lie
behind the data generating process and
to try and learn something based on
those assumptions
yes sorry to jump in i was just trying
to get back on the previous uh point so
just one thing i wanted to highlight uh
facebook that uh emma pogovich uh also
did uh work on backdoor criterion uh and
sort of tied up the the final um loose
end on
uh on
complete graphical characterization and
contraction of um adjustment sets for
for mags and tags um
and i was also going to say just briefly
the sdi algorithm is actually in peter's
book from 1993 so the original
version is in there um and the output is
pretty much the same as you get viewing
it as a as a
tag or as a pointy as you described it
the only difference is you get a couple
more orientations uh
there are certain
um circles that get replaced uh if you
view it as a pad but um
yeah although those also create issues
for people trying to do back door
adjustment so anyway that was just a
complete you you asked me to correct
anything so i'm just adding it in here
sorry thank you thank you yeah and
emma's paper on
on vector adjustment is one that i
probably should have included up there
as well
so thanks
um okay so
so so moving on uh so
the kind of non-parametric structural
equation framework is one in which every
variable is assumed to be some function
unspecified of its parents in a graph
with some
uh error term right
um so this is is super general in the
sense that it places no restrictions at
all on the observed data
and uh
and there's a kind of very weak
set of assumptions and then people start
making independence assumptions about
the errors and so forth on top of these
things but a kind of popular class of
structural equation models that is much
more restrictive or makes a much
stronger set of assumptions would be
linear models so in a linear model it's
like a special case where these f's are
just linear functions linear
combinations of the parents
um
so uh the kind of
interesting thing about uh making
somewhat parametric or semi-parametric
assumptions about the the functional
forms is that these can induce
a certain amount of asymmetry on the
data that can be helpful for causal
discovery
so
uh
um linear models are are popular they're
convenient to analyze and estimate um
they're very obviously not universally
applicable because there's lots of
examples of things that are
exhibit non-linearities
um
but if you do assume linearity
and in addition assume something about
the distribution of the error terms
in particular it's been shown that if
you are willing to assume that the
epsilons these errors are non-gaussian
or independent but non-gaussian
then that is sort of
is provably enough to induce a kind of
asymmetry
on the observed data joint distribution
which can help you identify a unique dag
instead of a markov equivalence class
it has a kind of long footnote here it's
not really common outside of causal
discovery very much to think about
linear
structural equations with non-gaussian
errors obviously gaussian errors are
very common in a lot of areas of
statistics and econometrics
but uh linearity and non-gaussianity of
the errors can coexist and this will
induce non-gaussianity on the joint
distribution over the x's right so the
kind of correspondence is that like if
you had gaussian errors and linear
functions that induces a gaussian joint
distribution
if i know that i have a gaussian joint
distribution then i know i have linear
functions but if i
have linear functions
that are non-gaussian then that will
introduce a non-gaussian journal
distribution over the x's and so in this
case this would be a model in which the
epsilons are
unspecified but not gaussian
and a kind of interesting observation
this is from a paper by
uh
hoyer at all from 2008
is that that kind of non-gaussianity in
the context of linear models
um induces these asymmetries which you
can observe in the residuals from
fitting those regressions
um
and
specifically just thinking about two
variables which we talked about earlier
as being kind of this impossible case
you
non-parametrically if i have two
variables
these
different structures all induce the same
dependent structure between x1 and x2
namely there is no independence
but can induce different
constraints on the covariances or on the
error residuals so as an example
if i think of x1 and x2 and then e1 and
e2 are the errors
then
model 2 is one in which x1 causes x2 and
so there's some coefficient alpha in the
linear structural equation model
um
model 3 is one in which the direction is
reversed so there's an alpha from x2 to
x1
and um
you can for each one of these cases
write down what is the induced variance
and covariance over the x's
and uh and see that if
if um if things were gaussian
then the covariance matrix the
covariance has this kind of symmetric
quality to it right like that there's
there's no way of distinguishing whether
i'm going in one direction or the other
just based on this
covariance matrix in the case where
things are gaussian but in the case
where things are non-gaussian the
residuals will sort of have different
orientations depending on which
direction
the influence goes so like a kind of an
example i think this
this
uh kind of simulation example
the last column is one in which the
noises are assumed to be uniform instead
of gaussian so that's an example of a
non-gaussian distribution whereas the
penultimate column is one in which the
noises are gaussian so for all of these
cases
in the in the gaussian
setting
all you all you can conclude from those
residuals is that there's an association
between x1 and x2 right a kind of linear
association in particular between x1 and
x2
but when you start allowing for uniform
noise you can see that the residuals
exhibit this kind of
um
asymmetry based on the thresholding
right so like that the the
walls of the residuals correspond to
like the direction of uniformity in the
first error and then there's
that's propagated to the second
dimension
and so this kind of principle
this principle of
allowing for or assuming
uh
a particular functional form for the
structural equations and something
asymmetric about the error distributions
can be used to distinguish between
possible candidates even even just with
two variables and even sometimes in the
case with a measured confounding so uh
as an example the kind of um
one algorithm that exploits this kind of
approach
is uh ica lingam so lingam is the kind
of general term for linear non-gaussian
acyclic model
and there's a lot of kind of different
algorithms for
learning lingam models
and the kind of classic one is based on
independent components analysis
so uh i can just i'll describe really
briefly how how it works and then talk
about the version that allows for
unmeasured variables so say say i assume
there's no latent variables first to
explain
um in that case you can show that
if a lingam model holds
then the algorithm may identify a new a
unique dag rather than an equivalence
class
um
and i'm sort of caught in the paper a
review paper uh by shohei shimisu is
down here in the footnotes
um
and the kind of but like a fundamental
thing to keep in mind here is that
you're you're drawing stronger
conclusions than you would if you were
using pc right you might learn a unique
dag instead of an equivalence class but
you're also making stronger assumptions
uh which may be diffusible that there's
this linear non-gaussian model
underlying your data
so the way that lingam kind of very
roughly works
is that um i can describe the linear
structural equation in matrix form as
above so like x is just b times x for
some matrix of coefficients
so sorry a question here
distribution of the epsilons is in the
gaussian cochlear family i guess so long
as it doesn't reduce to gaussian for
each one then it's non gaussian
the result is
the
joint is the joint
as long as each of the rest are
non-gaussian
so kind of like a gasoline includes
gaussians right so you can't you have to
say you have to like exclude that bit
because in the example that you show it
was about the dependence because the
correlation that you showed
structure
yeah i mean i think i guess the way that
i would put it is that
ultimately what it's going to do is
induce some sort of
uh
and do something about the covariance
between the x's right
but if you have
it's like how many degrees of freedom
there are in this ultimate covariance
matrix
i think i think it's just individual
errors as long as
you know more than one of them
some of them are non-gaussian you'll
have this asymmetry
i'm curious why no one asked it but they
will ask it what is the
precise notion of non-gaussianity means
that we are male
total
variation distance is epsilon far from
gaussian ocean
means
i i can find an enormous number of way
to
describe the normal
so
what is your interpretation
well there's going to be more than one
wave that is equivalent i think a lot of
the results in like the lingam
literature are kind of based on the
existence of higher moments
all right so for gaussians it'll just
there's no there's only the second
moment and that's it so as long as you
have non-zero higher moments
you can induce some asymmetry
but it kind of depends a bit on which
paper and which algorithm you're talking
about i think that's the way that it's
proved for this stuff
non-vanishing skew or ketosis
distribution is something like koshi
because in the picture that you showed
it's very obvious that they're different
because you have finite support but what
if you also have infinite support is
also symmetric
like this
[Music]
you might run into other problems
because
your moments might divert depends how
high you have to go so
it might be a different problem you'd
run into so i expect do you want this
thing to have moments of all orders
there's a difference between what
problems you're into practically
speaking in this setting versus what you
can prove about identifiability so i
think to identify built like usually
like for these papers typically they'll
prove that
under such and such assumptions about
the errors and structural equations
there is a
difference in the drug distribution
going one direction versus another and
so i think as long as you have higher
moments that are non-zero you can show
that there's a difference in those
distributions and how you actually
estimate those things with a particular
algorithm is kind of a separate story
and so usually they use or i mean one of
the basic approaches is using
independent components analysis
which i'll describe here and that kind
of depends on
you know
estimating some matrix such that
residuals look independent and that can
be
easier or harder to do depending on what
particular way you use to solve this
problem
so so really quick uh i just want to say
that so uh i started off by saying that
here's here's the linear model
in
matrix form
and here's the same model just turning a
into the identity matrix minus b with
the inverse
um and so in this model we'll say that
if if there's a coefficient then there's
a corresponding edge in the underlying
dag and so kind of what you want to
learn to learn the dag is those set of
coefficients
ica independent components analysis
will typically focus on estimating the
inverse of this a matrix
specifically the algorithm will find an
estimated
uh w in the inverse of a
such that
the resulting residuals look mutually
independent right which is the
underlying assumption of the linear
model
at least in the case without
latent variables
and the way it'll do that sort of
depends on the details but it's usually
based on minimizing this kind of
mutual information metric between the
the vector of error residuals um usually
requires some model for estimating those
mutual information pieces and so forth
but that's what
uh ica lingam
basically does
but a caveat to all this is that ica
will only estimate that matrix w hat
up to a permutation of the columns and a
scaling factor
and so there's going to be some
additional steps to go from that thing
you just estimated
to
be which is the thing of interest to
decide what your
parent relationships are like in the dag
so basically
these this kind of ica-based procedure
will proceed by
estimating w hat and then
using uh
kind of like looking at various
permutations of that estimated matrix
and normalizing the results and trying
to say that the really small entries of
that matrix are zero right so you have
to there's going to be some sort of
thresholding thing because you'll never
estimate both direct exact zeros so
you're going to have to prune the
coefficients close to zero and then sort
of work backwards to a beta to a b hat
um
and this is a i mean ica procedures are
like a huge
area of signal processing and
engineering the kind of tip if you're
not familiar with ica the typical
i don't know the kind of slogan by which
it's often described as solving this
cocktail party problem so like uh
imagining a room with people in a party
where people are close to possibly
different microphones that are listening
to conversations in the room and the
microphones linearly mix
conversations based on the distance from
different people and sort of unmixing
those independent sources
of variation is what ica that's kind of
all about there's huge literature and
like fast algorithms for for solving
that problem
how do you do it if you have latent
variables
well i think in this in this case
you have this
setting where you have more sources than
microphones so you're sort of imagining
that there's additional
errors which kind of represent your
latent variables that are these things
together are mutually
independent but they may affect uh
may
you may affect multiple of the x's for
example so the way this is done is by
doing a kind of over complete uh
independent components analysis that's
described in this paper in the footnote
so with two variables and allowing for
an unmeasured variable u it'll kind of
look like you have this asymmetric
coefficient matrix and this
uh column matrix of larger dimension
than your observed uh of your observed
data um and and in that case the way
that it kind of at least the kind of
classic version proceeds by using a
mixture of gaussians approximation
so it will
uh so
if you
represent each error as each
non-gaussian error as a mixture of
gaussians a weighted mixture of
gaussians you can write down what the
likelihood looks like given the whole
parameter set
and then under some assumptions you can
maximize that likelihood estimate those
parameters using a kind of em approach
and then you're gonna have to do again
this kind of permutation issue and
shrinking small coefficients to zero and
so forth that will in the end
where the ultimate goal is to recover
recover the
the
the elements of this mixture matrix
okay yes
do you need to know anything about
epsilon or
earlier and most one of them can be
calcium
all right it's positive
frederickson
yeah
okay
um but uh but also it's worth mentioning
in practice um
at least using this kind of mixture of
gasoline approach
how dousy and how non-gaussian the
errors is makes a big difference too
right like if they're too close to
gaussian you're going to do poorly
because they're not identifiable if
they're too far away from gaussians then
they're going to be poorly approximated
by a mixture of a mixture of gaussians
for some finite number of mixtures
um and so there's a kind of trade-off
between
uh how non-gaussian
things will be for in order for this
particular estimation procedure to
perform well
um and i mean that's actually i think
there's a kind of
there's open questions and results that
one could try and prove about like the
degree of non-gaussianity and how
how well that lets you recover the
lingam model and even in this in this
linear case
and it's also worth mentioning that in
the case even though like a major
benefit
or a major i don't know pro of of the
lingam approach in the dag setting is
the fact that you can
recover a unique dag that part's not
really true once you start allowing for
latent variables because there'll be
multiple
observationally equivalent
um
uh uh like latent variable models with
different coefficients that uh
are consistent with your data and so in
the in the case of latent variable
lingam
you're actually going to return
a kind of equivalence class of dags but
it's not necessarily
an equivalence class in the same sense
that a cp dag uh a cp dag works
okay
so so
the general so i'm not going to go too
much deeper into the linear non gaussian
stuff
but there is this existing literature a
major pro is this ability to identify
are we sometimes a unique dag or a
relatively small equivalence class in
the case of latent variable models
um uh
the cons i would say is that firstly on
the side of like assumptions there's uh
you know they're strong assumptions even
with allowing for non-gaussianity the
linearity assumption is quite strong
the statistical or asymptotic properties
of these ica-based algorithms are not
really
clear
in a lot of cases in particular like
results about how far away you are from
the correct solution i think will depend
on a lot of things including something
about the degree of non-gassianity
uh if errors are either too close to
gaussian or two non-gaussian it's
probably not going to perform well and
in practice it often requires large
sample sizes and relatively small
dimensions
yes sorry i just wanted to add a little
footnote here which is that there is
some work it's it's very recent so it's
just within the last it was published
last uh it was published in 2020 but
there's a paper by
wang and uh mathias certain on high
dimensional causal discovery under
non-gastate in biometrica and that paper
does present statistical guarantees and
it also recovers a bag with bi-directed
edges um so
yeah so that so in a certain sense it
does address some of the gaps that you
were just highlighting which i think
were gaps until very recently but um
yeah
and one other question is uh
is there no assumption and faithfulness
we're thinking of just the
assumption about the functional form
good question kind of tricky so
um faithfulness is often not mentioned
explicitly in the literature on lingam
models but there is a kind of
faithfulness that ends up being assumed
in the sense that
certain faithfulness violations will
mess up the algorithm
so um there's a recent paper
um there's a recent paper by constantine
jenin and
i think they talk about this
some uniform consistency result for
linear models
so i guess i guess the summary point is
that yes and no there's like
faithfulness does not play quite a
central a role in the theoretical
results related to lingam models
but also
uh violations of faithfulness
in some cases will mess up these
algorithms and lead them to perform
poorly so there's like a kind of
sneak thing faithfulness i would say
that makes an appearance
that brings a little bit about the
convention
i think what what what is the dimension
here is that the p is the number of
variables just the number of zeros
so i'm just making a kind of an
empirical practical observation that
computationally is difficult and
accuracy-wise it's not great once you
let p be quite large so if i'm doing it
with like and in what space
are the variables themselves
uh
the the x's themselves are here
continuous variables that can follow
any distribution except for gaussian in
a sense right so are they on the real
line or yes so for a linear model
of each variable
[Music]
i don't know a theoretical result of
that form i'm using i'm making a purely
like empirical observation about the dna
computation difficult yeah
so with the linearity
of
function being being being strong
i would guess that what you could do is
you could define like
how many vari variables
where you where you raise the variables
that you have to higher powers and
you know you could possibly deal with
with that you can use kernel net methods
what are the reasons that like those
things would like break and not and not
work here
um
the question is about sort of trying to
weaken the linearity assumption by
say allowing for polynomials in your
variables or something like that so you
can go in that direction it becomes a
bit complicated because now
it's like say i just did that and i said
for every x let me also add x squared
and assume it's linear in that kind of
quadratic thing
now there's no longer a single
coefficient that corresponds to the edge
being present or absolute right so like
the nice thing about linear models is
that if b
are going back to here like if b i j is
not equal to zero that's like means that
there's an edge there
now if i start thinking about like
polynomials in x i have to make some
decisions about how to treat that like
how to
do the correspondence between this like
non-linear function or like a set of
coefficients representing this
non-linear function and the dag itself
i don't think it's impossible but it
just like adds for a layer of
complexity there
um
and
and these results that i've talked about
so far also
like the linearity
in x
is crucial for using this ica-based
stuff
there is non-linear ica
work that
that has been leveraged to do this in a
kind of non-linear setting but still
using the ica approach but it's like a
little bit different and i won't talk
about it here
and then
instead rather i was going to talk a
little bit about
a kind of weakening of the linear
non-gaussian acyclic model and thinking
about these additive models which is
kind of like another
um what you might think is like a
natural second step um but i think
before i get into that i think there's
another
question here
so
maybe i'm not the fan of lingam okay
maybe it's my issue but
what i'm trying a little bit to
understand intuitively
what i got is that uh
i wish the the lack of gaussianity would
offer me uh
enough asymmetry in order to find out a
unique dog
but
that's
does not work in my mind with the
generality that we have expressed the
non-gaussian difficult program if i put
laplace distribution that is
non-gaussian but it has like
all the similar properties that someone
can think
like gaussian it seems that
it will work so
what i am losing
into it
the results about non-christianity
would play
if i used a laplace distribution and
laplace distribution seems to behave iso
parametrically
it's so nice like a distribution in
comparison with uh
that's higher order
so like you can in the same sense you
can test whether you're in a gaussian or
laplacian setting you're looking at
those higher bonuses right
and so the ica kind of based procedures
which
exploit non-gaussianity to do this like
mutual information stuff they'll be
different whether it's gaussian or
laplace
we will discuss it offline i think
it is clear
is there another question yeah
it's more of a
practical question so let's say i have a
data set and then i know all these
methods and then i run each of these on
the data set and then
i get a different graph
for these methods so is there any ways
that i can
verify which one works better for my
dataset particularly
or
i would how do i know which one it's
good
so the question to repeat for folks on
zoom is if i if i have all these
different methods and i run each one on
a particular data set how do i know
which one is the best or most
appropriate there's no easy answer to
that question it depends also what you
know about the truth
so in a simulation setting when i know
what the true structure is because i've
simulated it i can straightforwardly
compare which method gets me closer to
the truth right in terms of
structural hamming distance or false
positives or precision and recall or
whatever it is but in a lot of real
applications the reason you're doing
causal discovery is because you don't
know the truth so there's not going to
be unless you can go ahead and like
validate something about the graph you
learned by doing say experiments
then there's not necessarily going to be
a straightforward way to determine
whether
uh you are
closer to the truth with one graph or
another i mean you can do certain things
like evaluate like at least for certain
classes of models you can evaluate the
fit of those models and see which one
fits better by some metric
but um
[Music]
but there's no
easy way to compare if you're doing
better in one versus the other unless
you know something substantive about the
true model do you think um
like the stability of the address would
play a role in here let's say i divide
the data set into like 100 times
yeah so the questions about stability of
edges and there are definitely papers
that take that route that sort of do sub
sampling
and see how often a particular edge
appears or doesn't appear and you can
come up with
a
different
evaluation methods for deciding like how
confident you are in a particular edge
and that is one one route to go down
so uh so if i can i'll
what time are we going to until four
i mean
um so there's this
uh
other kind of semi-parametric work that
instead of assuming linear non-gaussian
stuff
um goes in the direction of uh additive
noise models with nonlinear functions so
this is one where the epsilon is
additive with respect to
f of the parents
um somewhat surprisingly
you if you if you're even
if you assume gaussian noise here but
non-linear functions so as long as
there's some non-linearity you can also
uh that's sufficient to identify the
causal structure uniquely
but
from the perspective of this lecture
which is kind of focused on variables
that are immutable to unmeasured
confounding and latent and hidden
structure a problem with the additive
noise model setting is that this class
is not closed under marginalization so
if i start if i think about a dag over x
and l
satisfying
um
the
a m the additive noise model and then i
marginalize over the l and just think
about the induced structural equation
model on the x's that's no longer
guaranteed to be in this additive noise
class so it's not really one that's easy
or amenable to
kind of a marginal latent variable
setting
um there's a kind of
iteration on that uh that tries to relax
things in it even further what's called
the post-non-linear causal model which
basically takes an additive noise model
and then runs it through an additional
non-linear but invertible function
um
and so there's some some results that
under certain kind of technical
conditions by the way some of those
technical conditions kind of do resemble
faithfulness in a more obvious sense
because they rule out certain kinds of
cancellations
um
the then you can show that there's a
asymmetry induced on the joint
distribution and that those directions
can be distinguished from data
um to
end this little point i all of these
kind of semi-parametric methods impose
some assumptions or restrictions on the
structural equations
derive some sort of asymmetry on the
observed data distribution
and then check
if the data exhibits the supposed
asymmetry to try and infer backwards um
i think there's a lot of open questions
about the properties of such methods and
they can be computationally quite
difficult but one kind of nice thing
combined is combining them with the
existing methods so there are times in
which people have run say pc or ges or
something similar and then
reduce the size of the equivalence class
by additionally imposing one of these
additive noise model type things or
lingam model type things to get more
informative output so long as those
additional structural uh
conditions are met so and there are also
new methods
in this kind of space that are being
developed all the time
i want to i want to say a little bit
about a a different paradigm for causal
discovery which may be of particular
interest to people here at simon's
um because it draws on
kind of more
cutting edge
stuff in
uh in
optimization literature
so there's a recent
set of
proposals which combine a kind of score
based selection with ideas from
continuous optimization and often in
practice parametric or semi-parametric
assumptions
for example
if you
if you say assume that the true data
generating process is some sort of
structural equation model say like a
linear structural equation model or
whatever it might be with some set of
parameters theta
and let g of theta
uh denote the corresponding graph that
basically counts the non-zero entries
and
in your parameter matrix
and use this kind of
boldface g to denote a space of possible
graphs that you might want to search
over for example the space of all dags
over some variables x or the space of
all mags or pags over variables x
and then let a score and then define a
score function kind of similar to bic
that maps uh some
parameter vector estimated for a graph
to higher lower numbers depending on
whether it's a better fit then the
kind of differentiable approach
recasts the discrete search over
possible graphs into a continuous search
over parameter values
by basically saying
i want to find a value of theta that
minimizes some score
such that the implied
uh
graph g for those thetas is in the class
that i'm willing to consider for example
the class of dags
and if you can find a function of theta
that is zero if and only if
g is in that class
then now this becomes a continuous
constrained optimization problem
so the key there's a bunch of moving
parts here of course but say
once you define a score and a model
class
uh the sort of key challenge is like a
a function of theta
that is continuous and differentiable
such that zero of that function is an
indicator that you're in the right class
for example the class of directed
acyclic graphs so the original version
of this uh this algorithm called no
tiers
considers linear structural equation
models so the thetas are the linear
coefficients
and they and they show that um
the induced graph is a cyclic they're
interested in directed acyclic graphs if
and only if this particular h evaluates
to zero so this is something that looks
like the trace of the matrix exponential
of uh theta times theta where this is
the the dot is the uh hadamard product
the element wise product of the two
matrices so that's a function which
takes the theta matrix multiplies it by
another theta matrix takes the
exponential and takes the trace and then
subtracts off the number of variables p
and and so that that quantity will
vanish if there are no cycles in the
graph
question of that uh yeah you have a
statement that you need to assume that
the like it's actually the true theta
exists in this class does it need to be
like a true theta or is there a notion
of like in statistics of like best in
class so like the closest with whatever
your losses that your score functions
the fact is
i think you probably could formulate it
that way you just won't have the kind of
consistency results i guess maybe i'm a
little biased in the sense that i like
consistency results but yeah you can you
can probably formulate this as just like
the one that minimizes some loss
yeah so so in this particular case to
summarize it quickly um
the author is sort of formulating this
this search problem as a continuous
optimization problem so they have this
constraint that you can evaluate and
solve you can take derivatives of and so
you can use kind of state-of-the-art
constrained optimization techniques to
try and solve this problem in a kind of
continuous way
notice this assumes linear
models right so you have to have some
parameter vector that basically defines
the dag for you
and it's not always so straightforward
to figure out how to relax that because
of problems kind of like the ones i
mentioned earlier
but
it is a kind of nice or interesting
formulation because you can now exploit
a lot of
existing stuff from the optimization
literature uh to do this well so in
practice people have used mostly the
augmented lagrangian
approach and uh in another paper this
has been extended to mixed graphs so
admgs of different classes in particular
mags
as well as other kinds of admgs that i
mentioned in a second
again assuming a linear structural
equation model except now i have uh both
coefficients
and covariances between my
my errors to represent that unmeasured
confounding
and
so now if i define my space g to be the
space of ancestral graphs you can show
that i can define this h function
which
again is a
a continuous and differentiable function
of a bunch of matrix parameters that is
zero if and only if the graph is
ancestral
so the first part of it is basically
just asyclicity and then the second part
of it
counts the number of ancestrality
violations
so uh so if i define this kind of thing
i can do the same procedure try and
minimize some sort of score metric while
satisfying this constraint on the
parameters um
and uh
in the papers that i've seen
the kind of
approach has been mostly to minimize
the score using this kind of
lagrange augmented lagrange multiplier
approach solving the dual equation and
there's like a million things probably
to be said about the
stability and convergence properties of
different optimization schemes here but
this is not something i'm personally
very knowledgeable so i won't say more
about it there is a recent paper that
compares a few different or mostly
theoretically compares a few different
approaches to
uh to to solving this optimization
problem
um
and that might be of interest to folks
and then
uh oh yeah and these are a couple of
references that's the in terms of the
scores that people use
the the approach proposed by by jenga at
all uh use the kind of l1 penalized
likelihood score for dags
uh which i don't think is really
consistent in their setting
uh in another paper by uh bhattacharya
and company and full disclosure i was a
co-author on that paper uses a different
score that's an approximation to the bic
score
um
uh so that involves basically fitting
likelihoods for admgs and then
penalizing them somehow and calculating
the derivative of that h function
for which we use this procedure that
thomas richardson alluded to earlier
about
calculating maximum likelihood estimates
for mags
um and another kind of caveat that is
worth emphasizing is that these
procedures
are kind of blind to equivalence class
considerations
the approach so far has been
to sort of hope you achieve a global
optimum and then
that will be one dag or one admg in the
equivalence class and then transform it
to a representation of the equivalence
class like a cp dag or a pag
and that is one way to go there are
issues with local optima in this case
and it's also
harder if you try and extend this so in
the paper that
i was somewhat involved in we tried to
extend this to
more general classes of adm gs besides
mags but the issue is that there's like
no there's a lot of unanswered questions
about markov equivalence in that setting
so
there's a lot that's really kind of
unclear about how to do that properly
um
i'll skip this little bit
i wanted to mention really quickly
uh a bit about another related approach
that's kind of also
optimization based in some sense
this permutation based approach to
causal discovery which formulates a
score maximization problem over
permutations
of the vertices in a graph
so
specify kind of abstractly if you think
about some space of possible
permutations of the vertices in a graph
and the dag or admg or whatever that
those permutations induce you can try
and search over possible permutations
and for each permutation calculate some
score try and
minimize that score or in this case
maximize
so permutation is like just thinking of
the vertices as like an ordered like a
list of numbers
ordering them in some way such that the
order reflects parent-child
relationships in the graph as a total
order or a partial order if you're just
thinking about ancestrality
relationships
um
so
you can you can define so work by by
carolyn uhler and her collaborators
defines a kind of score that's based on
the the sparsity of the resulting graph
and searches for permutations that
minimize or i guess maximize that score
uh
phrase this way
um this is kind of i'd say
on the surface it's like kind of a score
based approach but in reality it might
be better thought of as a hybrid
approach because it involves uh
maximizing some sort of score but it
also in practice involves testing a
bunch of independence constraints so you
have to look for permutations that are
consistent with the data in some sense
so they will test so here i'm using kind
of abstractly like the set of
independence constraints implied by a
graph but in practice you need to test
those conditional independence
constraints to determine whether your
permutation is a candidate for for a
possible graph or not so they do this in
a couple of different um
papers including one approach that
focuses on causal orderings
corresponding to dags and uh and then
more recently an approach that looks at
partial orders which corresponds to
corresponds to
ancestral graphs or mags
so there's a lot of interesting problems
and questions uh that kind of
flow from this this approach and then uh
i have i have a couple slides at the end
that just
uh you know
a non-exhaustive list of different kinds
of algorithms in the space of caldwell
discovery that are color coded by my
kind of personal color coding scheme so
we have approaches that learn dags and
cp dags we have approaches that learn
mags or pags or admgs of some sort and
we have approaches that learn cyclic
graphs that i haven't had time to talk
about today and in each of these
categories you have things that are kind
of
uh constraint based like pc and fci
and ccd which is cyclic causal discovery
you have approaches that are score based
like the ges or these two algorithms i
just described the sparses permutation
algorithms
um as well as stuff based on
maximum hill climbing
you have approaches based on these
semi-parametric assumptions we just
discussed including ica lingam but sort
of other lingam related uh variables and
there's a version of lingam that's for
cyclic models just that's just called
ling
and then we have stuff that doesn't
really fit in super neatly into any of
these categories like methods based on
sat solvers and these differential
causal discovery uh approaches
um here's a kind of partial list also of
software packages that are available for
uh structure learning in
an r in python and java matlab and so
forth and finally i'll conclude with
just a couple of open problems i guess
to
to stimulate uh discussions here at
simon's
including i think most of these i've
kind of mentioned along the way
better general purpose non-parametric
conditional dependence tests i think are
super helpful and helpful for making
algorithms especially like pc and fci
but also score based stuff more flexible
in in non-parametric settings there's a
lot of room
i was asked earlier about greedy uh
score based methods for mags and tags
and so there's a lot of room for
for consistent scalable non-parametric
and more algorithms for learning mags
and tags or other classes of admgs
there's kind of theoretical questions
that might help in the search for
general admgs about characterizing
markov equivalents for those kinds of
graphs
a better understanding of methods for
learning graphs that combine confounding
and cycles
i think are really interesting so these
would be directed mixed graphs without
the acyclicity bit
um there's a lot of they're open
questions about consistency results that
weaken the strong faithfulness
assumption and then there is the kind of
broad question of
statistically speaking how to do valid
post selection inference so given that
you've selected a model and you might
want to use the same data to then
subsequently estimate some sort of
causal effect or some interventional
distribution
treating that model as if it were known
if you do that in a kind of naive way
your
quantification of uncertainty will not
be
valid your confidence intervals will not
have the correct coverage and so there's
like a large literature and
post-selection inference in
other branches of statistics like in
linear model selection and i think
there's kind of a lot of open questions
for how to do that properly in this
space of the kind of discrete
graph based model selection that we do
when we do
causal discovery so i'll end with i'll
end with that and i'm happy to
answer questions and stick around if
people want to talk thanks for listening
[Applause]
we can do questions afterwards let me
just say because we're out of time for
tomorrow um let me repeat what i said
before thomas will be doing this online
he'll be on screen here we'll have
microphones for questions from the room
obviously you can do this from home if
you are at home uh
unless you are a panelist or a member
for the
program for the whole term you will only
be able to ask that
actually
you would better come into the room i
will be here it would be great to not be
the only one here
it's nice to not have to drink the
coffee on my own
so but i completely understand that you
want to do it for a moment
thank you very much and
hopefully i'll see many of you tomorrow
if not here than online
yeah they are available so the slides
are on my website under the teaching
tab and i think they're sending them
around